So computational complexity is the problem of actually finding the hardness of problems
and from the prospective of a theoretician who studies complexity theory,
the stuff that we've been doing so far talking about devising algorithms
and proving their running times, that's just part of the story, that's just upper bound determination.
There's a whole other set of work that has to go into
finding lower bounds on the hardness of problems and that requires
very different techniques from the kinds that we've talking about up to this point.
So it's worth pointing out what theoreticians often really like to do
is that they find an upper bound for the hardness of their problem and they can find a lower bound
that matches it, then you know exactly the complexity of the problem.
It has to lie between those and they match, so therefore, it's exactly that.
So as I said, we're not going to get very involved in proving lower bounds for different problems,
but this argument is actually not too hard and I'll give you a little flavor
for how this can be done in some cases.
Imagine that we're trying to compute the max of a list of (n).
Now we know an upper bound on this problem is Θ(n)
because we can just loop through all the elements in the list find the maximum.
But how do we argue about a lower bound for this problem?
Well, one argument might be, well, constant time is a lower bound on this problem
Because at the very least, you have to give the answer. It takes at least constant time to do that.
It's possible you can even do that well
if you're trying to compute the max of a list and you guessed a number,
if may very well be the max, so that gives us a lower bound.
Here's another one, Θ(n) might be on lower bound, why?
Because you have to at least look at all the n items; otherwise, there could be one item in the list
that is the max that you didn't look at and so you can't possible return the right answer.
All right another argument might be something like this.
We have a lower bound of (log n) for the problem
because finding the max is sort of like finding the winner of a tournament.
You have to compare values against other values
and we might be able to actually eliminate half each time,
and if we could do that, then the number of rounds that it would take before we have a winner
in a tournament of individuals in a single elimination tournament,
it's like it's (log n), so which of these do you think is the best argument
in terms of a lower bound for finding the max?